Hello Freak bitches,
Pokemon,
the Pokemon games,
taking it to the next level because now it explain what's going on.
It's way to,
to say what Pokemon is.
It takes Google maps,
you have to sign into Google,
it takes Google maps and all the information that's in Google maps and it makes
it the level of video game.
So instead of playing a level,
you're playing your own street,
you're finding you're finding creatures in your house.
And uh,
so yeah,
so then there's places like churches are called Jim's.
That's where you go.
And if you go to a church,
uh,
you can train your fighter to be stronger and stuff like that.
So you're using real world,
uh,
places and like,
like landmarks and you're finding things that like water fountains.
Like if you go to the water fountain,
there's a bunch of coins there.
So it's using the,
and what's crazy is like if you're at the comedy store it on Google maps,
you can like upload your own photos,
you know,
like,
like I was at the comedy store it on Google maps,
so it pulls that information also.
So if you're playing the game,
you'll be like,
oh,
there's Andy Kaufman sign.
If we go to the Andy Kaufman sign,
we can get some treasures and it shows you the Andy Kaufman sign in the video
game.
But here's the crazy thing.
In one like two days,
it's almost every single person has downloaded it and played it.
And the crazy thing I was thinking of is how awesome is it that it's connected
to Google and we're sending cause it,
it opens your camera at parts of the game when you're battling and it's scanning
your room,
your houses,
and it's sending it to Google.
So this is like the best way that Google is now getting a complete map of our
house inside.
It's uh,
like it's,
it's scanning every street and like one year your Google is going to be able to
have to see every single inch of every single place inside and outside because
of this game.
How long has it been out?
Like three days,
right?
Three days.
Sorry,
I'm more phones on android than Tinder.
And it's about the past.
Twitter.
Yeah.
I really think we should bring typewriters back.
I'm sorry.
And no one's thinking about this though,
weren't just low.
Opening our camera and recording our rooms and sending it to Google can wait a
minute.
Is this real
Joe [inaudible] disposal?
I knew we were going to talk about it.
So I pulled up some stuff already.
There's like a,
the interesting thing that's happening with it being on open gps maps is those
places,
those locations,
like there's a guy's home that's been turned into one of these gyms and he's
like mad that people are showing up outside of it.
Yeah.
Place.
It's because he bought an old church and so churches in the game automatically
become Jim.
So people are hanging out.
Yeah.
Outside
of his house now.
But also interesting things like this has happened.
Where are the west boat?
Westboro Baptist Church has been overtaken by a gay friendly Pokemon.
And so people were like kind of,
I don't know necessarily trolling them and whatnot,
but then,
uh,
so by walking around and looking for things,
a teenager found a dead body somewhere and just three days they've already
dead body found by teenager hunting water Pokemon.
She found it underneath the bridge.
Oh my
God.
This part two
I was trying to get a water,
Pokemon Wiggins totes,
CNN.
Instead she made the alarming and alarming discovery,
a dead body close to the Wyoming highway seven 89 bridge.
I probably would have never went down there if it weren't for this game.
She admitted,
but the scary incident isn't deterring her and says she will continue to play.
I saw somebody playing on the highway on the way here.
I saw somebody playing on the highway.
It's bad enough we don't need the last night when I was waiting for my Uber at
my house,
I just three minutes,
I saw two different groups of kids,
like one on skateboards and one on bikes just playing the game and what's scary
is like on that article now armed robbers are robbing people at certain places
in the game because they know the kids are going to be there with like new
phones like I phones and stuff.
So they're waiting at certain places coming out stealing our phones.
Oh.
Because it's same allows players to drop module in a real world location to
attract high numbers of Pokemon for 30 minutes.
The lure modules have reportedly also been used by business owners to bring
people to their stores.
What?
Say,
oh,
so this is the next level.
This is,
this is what starts the next level,
this kind of thing.
The next level of
Internet,
augmented reality,
it's going to take over and it's also scanning,
just like snapchat scanned all our faces using all these filters now and they
have perfect,
they could three d model all our faces now because we,
we've been I her or faces now,
they ever,
they're scanning the whole entire United States.
They're going to have maps of everything inside and outside in like less than a
year.
Well,
do you think,
didn't we think though that eventually that that was going to be inevitable and
that was going to be unavoidable?
There's the technology's gonna dissolve all the windows.
Well,
this is the next is dissolving in the windows.
No more curtains.
That's also fascinating that it's an augmented reality.
Like,
that's what God,
everybody in like that.
The augmented reality is what snuck everybody in and then everybody's like,
Oh man,
let's play a game.
And then you're completely sucked into this very bizarre new world where you're
playing a game but wrapped around your own actual environment.
What he's showing.
This guy owns the gym of that guy's house,
so virtual owner of the property technically,
and it can be Kenyan or stolen or taken her
John.
Woo Hoo.
I met the owner of my gym.
Nice guy.
Oh my God.
He's like a,
yeah,
please don't tell anybody where I live,
dude.
Get away from my apartment,
my house.
I mean,
they're going to get sued.
Those Pokemon people are going to get sued for sure.
There's going to be a lot of lawsuits about this game.
There's going to be a lot of people dying.
I,
like I said on the way here,
I saw somebody using it while driving because you,
do you think that dead body was somebody trying to get a water Pokemon invest
and no,
that dead body was probably somebody murdered or a homeless person.
Yeah.
I mean it doesn't have to be,
but he could have been under that.
Where's the water?
Well there's some neat,
okay.
When you find something,
find like a water lord.
Is that what it was?
Yeah,
no,
it's an alert.
It's this thing that you can drop on the ground.
And so did someone drop it where the home was,
where the dead person was?
No,
she was just searching for Pokemon go.
It's kind of,
it reminds me of like when you're a kid,
you know when your bicycle bicycle and you're going around in your neighborhood
like playing adventure,
like looking at things and finding things.
It's kind of like that.
They makes you kind of go out in your neighborhood.
You look at stuff like,
I didn't know that there was like a Buddha across the street and like this
forest by my house and I found out by this game cause it was like go here,
you know,
there's some stuff here.
And so it's Kinda cool because it shows you around your neighborhood and stuff
like that that you might've not known.
It's kind of like that old game,
that Geo tagging game that people used to play where it's like go to these
coordinates and you'll find like a present.
And you know if you got really cynical you'd be,
it's like,
it's like some sort of an alien talking to you going move around your
coordinates and take photographs of everything.
So I can repeat it perfectly.
It's really interesting to see what businesses businesses are doing.
Like dairy queen,
like I said,
dropped something on the ground and it's like paying customers only can come
here and get came on.
So that's probably smart.
Yeah,
that's smart for them.
Can you mad like I grew up in south Philly,
we didn't look at anything and if we saw something we just kept walking.
Well we don't have to do that anymore Eleanor.
There's no more slaves.
And now you don't have to ride a horse around taking pictures around my mom's
neighborhood.
So let me explain to me,
cause let me understand how this works.
You're playing it.
So if you're playing it like what are you seeing right?
You see on the ground right now?
I see nothing I'm looking around.
I could see down the street there's uh,
some,
some cool places to get more coin or it's called pokey balls,
which you use to capture.
These places exist.
How they just like,
they just decide that the things are there.
It's random.
But what they usually do is they take certain things in Google maps,
like all their churches are gyms where you go to workout and stuff like that.
Your pokemons.
Then they take like,
like things like the comedy store and they put certain like they know it's a
landmark so they,
they,
there's a lot going on there.
Like last night,
if you go to the comedy store now,
you haven't been there in a couple of days.
Every single person's playing,
every single person working.
There's playing every comic.
There's,
everyone's just out there on their phones.
How this happens so quick,
it's,
it's huge man.
It's,
I just heard about this like maybe two days ago,
two days ago I saw a couple of pictures and April fool's joke
on youtube,
this video of what know someone made a fake application.
I looked like this and it turned out to be a really good idea that someone took,
develop,
develop.
It does now
overnight.
It's doing it because it really hits this nerve and your head of collecting
things and when you're going like,
look at,
I've collected,
w will look what I've collected and it's the perfect thing to do when you're
bored.
Like I was in an Uber.
I'm just sitting there while we're driving by the Hollywood bowl.
I'm like,
oh,
there's some cool stuff here.
I'm going to get here.
So it's a good thing to do when you're,
you have nothing else to do.
What do you mean get it as long as your phone?
It's like you're collecting virtual items.
Like whoa.
Pokemon chasing investors led oh 10 Nintendo's goal.
Go out there and make,
just make it smaller.
Send in tendo shares soar and craze added 9 billion in market value.
Two gave me company,
Nintendo was hurtin.
Mathinna was hurting before this.
Come on.
This is incredible.
The,
okay,
so you're walking around explaining this to me.
I'm looking at this person holding their hand and said they're walking around
and they have like a phone open where the,
they see the image of what's in front of them.
But Pokemon stuff is just sort of floating around.
Yeah.
Oh my God,
this is crazy.
And then you could grow eggs,
you can share,
share are,
you can train your characters to be stronger and then you can battle other
characters at gyms.
And,
and it's,
and this is by the way,
is just the first version.
They just,
you know,
they're,
they're going to be adding so much to this.
And what's interesting to note,
I heard a rumor maybe that the new grand theft auto is going to be doing the
same thing.
So you're going to be playing grand theft auto using Google maps.
So you're going to be at your house and your house is going to be your house.
And so this is just the beginning of this whole idea of taking Google's
information.
And I think giving them the people outside one.
One of the things is that they're already saying that people are are like kids
are complaining about sore legs and like
maybe this would be the video game that fixes fixes people who are addicted to
video games.
Yeah.
I mean that's wow.
Only positive thing.
I see her,
I'll just hanging around playing with each other.
Oh my God,
this is insane.
This is like the comedy store lesson.
Comicon in San Diego is going to be a zoo.
Yeah,
I forgot about stuff like that is fucking insane.
I can't believe I just legs.
Is that from being sore?
That's like the Mother Teresa.
I also heard that they banned it in San Francisco,
but I haven't looked to see if that's true or not.
Like some cities are actually banning it because people are not paying
attention.
Just going into traffic and there was probably a lot of them on the four oh five
today.
Oh,
I solved them.
If you think about it,
this is probably just the next step in what we're eventually going to get,
which is some sort of a reality that we can manipulate all the time.
Like this is one part of it.
We're going to have a little games in the regular reality,
but you could just have to look through your phone to see it.
But how long before that's glasses that you're wearing?
Like that Microsoft Shit?
Yeah.
What?
What is it called again?
Magic leap.
That's one.
I think that's the Google one.
Microsoft Hollow Lens is a,
are they both with goggles?
Both augmented reality bit there.
Both developed around augmented reality supposedly magically leap.
It's supposed to be awesome.
I don't want to say so.
No one likes regular
reality.
Anyone come on.
If you have a pair of glasses,
if you just put on a pair of glasses that you put on a pair of like they live
style,
I mean,
Jesus Christ,
they live is going to be real.
You put on a pair of glasses and then you see and you see all kinds of crazy
shit.
Yeah.